le goût de la vie d'après les danois
peuvent enfin le savourer à partir de ce
mercredi le danemark ce confinement
allégé depuis le mois de décembre a
décidé de lever les restrictions
sanitaires avant la fin mai date
initialement prévue
les restaurants les commerces ou encore
les salles de sport peuvent donc
accueillir leurs clients
seule condition pour dîner à l'intérieur
le corona passe application qui permet
d'attester de la vaccination contre le
coc u19 ou d'un test pcr négative de
moins de trois jours j'ai juste subi un
test rapide hier afin que nous puissions
réservés parce qu'on a besoin d'être
testé pour pouvoir manger à l'intérieur
on peut s'asseoir à l'extérieur son test
mais si on veut manger à l'intérieur on
doit avoir un test aujourd'hui on se
sent soulagé enthousiaste heureux c'est
juste une journée fantastique et nous
sommes impatients que ce soit espérons
le tout à fait complet ce soir c'est bon
d'être ouverts pour retourner dans les
écoles les entreprises les centres
commerciaux ou encore les salons de
tatouage les danois doivent se munir
d'un test pcr négative de moins de trois
jours je pense que nous avons fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour faire
fonctionner notre société et si cela
coûte un petit est un petit coton dans
la bouche pendant deux secondes
nous le ferons tous donc oui nous sommes
opérationnels et nous en sommes heureux
grâce à une campagne de dépistage
intensive et régulière le danemark
entame comme le royaume uni sa vie
d'après prochaine étape vacciner tous
les danois de plus de 16 ans avant la
fin du mois de juillet